planes
[Music]
trains
[Applause]
and Automobiles
sure these marvels of modern technology
can get you somewhere fast
but are they worth all the hassle and
risk
no you deserve better
you deserve an airship
and not just any airship
I'm offering you a ride in Google
co-founder Sergey brin's Airship made by
the good people and lighter than air
that's right friends
airships are back again and they're
better than ever
[Music]
they're less slow
they're less noisy they have Windows
that open that's crazy
and now they're less flammable too
so come on down to my hometown of
Mountain View California and hit your
ride on the Pathfinder one
foreign
years ago I caught wind that Sergey Brin
was funding the construction of a secret
Airship right here at NASA Ames in
Mountain View
I saw some pictures of this early
Airship it got kind of obsessed with it
Sergey didn't want to talk about his
Airship but over the last couple years I
managed to ingratiate myself with the
guy who's bringing Sergey brin's Airship
to life
and today I'm going to take you guys in
to see this thing being made
[Music]
I'm Alan Weston and I'm the CEO of LTA
and I'm the first person to work on this
project we've got this beauty behind us
give us give us the basics this is
Pathfinder one this is 122 meters long
has about 28 tons of total lift it's
designed to cruise at maximum speed of
60 knots
could probably go over 2 000 nautical
miles in one leg
our mission is to expand and complement
existing humanitarian relief using
lighter than air technology and at the
same time reduce the carbon footprint of
Aviation
Al here might look like your average
Aviation nerd but I assure you he's not
[Music]
among other claims to fame he was a
member of the dangerous sports club
where he would do stuff like this
and this
he even performed one of the first
modern bungee jumps people had sort of
used Vines and things like that before
but you guys were the first ones to get
just a cord and jump off a bridge right
right it was April Fool's joke and so
yes
and they let somebody like you go work
for the Air Force after that actually
the Air Force thought it was pretty
funny
[Music]
much like Al airships have a fascinating
backstory
some of the first ones the U.S ever made
lived right here in this hangar
[Music]
almost a hundred years ago the Navy
began building airships in Ohio so they
could be flown to California
the Navy saw these craft is key to
Gathering intelligence and Performing
reconnaissance it was the Glory Days of
airships you've shown me some of these
slides just here in Silicon valleys
there were times when the sky was like
filled with airships and and then they
were doing amazing things I mean there's
one that was almost like an aircraft
carrier this was actually in 1932 and 33
there was a hook on the Airship and
biplanes were carried inside the Airship
they were refueled
[Music]
then of course airships had some very
bad PR
planes came along
and people lost interest in these
Majestic beasts large airships
disappeared in 1939. so like everything
people might think of those are all
blimps and the difference being a blimp
just has no rigid structure right this
is a rigid Airship with a skeleton and
so the skeleton defines the shape and Al
thinks he can bring these sexy
hard-bodied airships back
this time filled with nice non-flammable
helium so you've got this wonderful
history and you're like making it all
happen again right right Back to the
Future yes we're restarting we're
Awakening the sleeping Giants that's
what I like to say one of my favorite
phrases
can we do the horn
sure
I don't think anyone I've ever heard
anyone use it before
this is Carl tossick he's a mechanical
engineer I've known for years who really
gets around Silicon Valley
I asked him to give me The Grand Tour
it's a lot of scaffolding yeah it's
incredible
first glance it appears almost nothing
has changed in a hundred years but
really this thing is a mix of the super
old and the super new so this is one of
12 of the electric motors that Propel
the ship okay and it's uh you can see
it's Motors mounted on a pylon which can
rotate so think of this Airship as a
giant quadcopter all these are thrust
Vector they can be pointed in order to
lift the ship straight up or move
laterally and then hear this outer
material is a is kind of leveraged from
racing sailboats okay this is how it's
laced on and this is a kind of an
anachronism from the way airships were
built 100 years ago there's 40 000 of
these lacing tests each one is laced by
hand she's
[Music]
the Pathfinder one skeleton is made of
carbon fiber making it lighter and
stronger than past airships the ship
will run on diesel to start but LTA
hopes to switch to either solar or some
form of hydrogen power in the future
overall the Airship will be much slower
than a plane but at least the passengers
will feel virtuous about their carbon
footprint I've never been in a gondola
foreign
exceed about 10 people it's it's used
commercially for sightseeing by the
Zeppelin company on their NT airships
and so if you're doing like a
two three day Journey from London to New
York you just you're hanging out in here
in this space
admittedly for a futuristic Airship this
is an underwhelming interior but this
ship is just an experimental vehicle the
first of its kind and not for the public
and the company has bigger things in
mind than just leisurely Sky cruises I
think you guys are most interested in
any kind of disaster scenarios I mean
that's the heart of why you're making
this thing right when you arrive at a
disaster site you often show up and the
place is wrecked and so the port may not
be working you then have to get your
supplies to where the disaster is and
typically you know the roads are gone
helicopters are really expensive to
operate they have limited range and
limited capacity to lift things so
that's where an Airship can also help
and it's the cargo right I mean they can
carry a significant amount of stuff
right we've studied airships that could
carry up to 200 tons of cargo
our approach is scalable to build larger
airships that could carry even more
[Music]
well to snout
so this giant thing is like a
custom-made anchor kind of exactly this
is what we call our our Mass trailer
okay it's one of the major advantages of
an Airship all you need to land is one
of these portable masts you know we
really we hope to be flying by the end
of the year yeah there's a lot to do
still Al promised my two kids one of the
first first rides it'll be a great ride
your kids though flight test Engineers
just keep them safe
and as much as I want my kids waving to
me from the gondola on that very first
flight
I can't help but imagine things going
horribly disastrously wrong
it is unfortunate that airships are
synonymous with fiery death
but ever since that fateful day in 1937
one small town in Germany the home of
the Hindenburg has led a PR campaign to
resuscitate the airship's image
foreign
[Music]
the dream of the Zeppelin is alive in
friedrichshafen
[Music]
town is embedded with Airship propaganda
this is your gaseous God
there's a parallel world where this is
the norm
and I'll admit I'm jealous
as far as weird stories go this one is
wonderfully weird
count Ferdinand Von Zeppelin was a great
Airship Pioneer in the late 1800s and
early 1900s
the man could not be stopped
he convinced all of Germany to fund his
work in an early version of a
Kickstarter campaign and his company
even managed to convince the Allies into
letting Germany keep making airships
after World War One
the count died in 1917. shame
but he donated all his Zeppelin
intellectual property to the city of
friedrichshafen wonderbar
and bizarrely his inventions were picked
up by the Aerospace and Automotive
Industries turned into the basis of a
multi-billion Dollar Empire
friedrichshofen gets a big chunk of this
money today and its residents get free
vacations and free education as a result
well done count this is
um
foreign
[Music]
to the ground
maybe if there wasn't video and all this
reporting about this event maybe
airships wouldn't have fallen out of
favor as much as as they did for a
period
is
um
despite their reputation as both fiery
death traps and Nazi tools of War
I still want to ride one
[Music]
there she blows
my Airship awaits
everyone tells you how awesome the
experience is going to be now they've
talked me into it
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
this is crazy you can like you feel this
incline but so gently
[Applause]
holy man this is crazy
[Music]
I genuinely feel like a wizard it's like
it's so hard to explain
I like surfing in the sky
[Music]
of course the real Wizards sit up front
meet Catherine board
one of the Zeppelin flying Elite
it's got to be a relatively small Club
out of all the pilot clubs maybe this is
the the smallest or no notice whenever
you mention a pilot's name we tend to
know them
um it's a very small Club there are more
astronauts than Azure Pilots okay all
right and and so that means what we're
talking about like
maybe
15 Zeppelin Pilots okay
the great thing about flying an Airship
is it's fly by feel not by numbers
[Music]
big airplanes it's very much yeah okay
yeah there is a little a bit of feel and
skill when they finally actually do
touch the controls which is almost ever
fly out of a fly out of big airports
small airports
there's something like I don't know if
magical's the right word it's almost
like it's illusion in your head though
to see this big thing that kind of moves
yeah gracefully but slowly and it's just
so unlike any other craft you're using
it is
foreign
just looking at how you know the ship
loading and the central points the
center of gravity Central left all these
things are exactly the same because we
do float we float in the air um just
like a boat on the water the only
difference is you can't see the waves
yes
I gotta poke my head up wouldn't do that
yeah
[Music]
I feel like a dog full happiness and
everything
you know I don't love Heights but when I
stick my head out the window it's not
not scary or anything at all
so cool
now there are these startups trying to
build new airships this is like an
exciting time for you the idea that that
maybe we have new airships and and this
technology is coming back again is this
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
to find out if the Airship has a future
I headed back to America
did I take a Zeppelin
only in my dreams
if lighter than air is successful then
the future of the Airship will take
place not in Germany or Silicon Valley
but here in Akron Ohio Where it All
Began in the first place
the Navy airships USS Akron and USS
Macon were built here in the 1930s
Goodyear kept going with this work and
created its blimping Empire
now lighter than air has taken over this
facility known as the air dock
that's where sergey's even bigger
airships will come to life
thank you for joining us here in the
Akron Air dock behind me you can see the
beginning of our next Airship that we're
building right here in Akron it will be
the largest airship built in the United
States since the Macon was built in
1932.
this is our very first test section and
this is where we're going to build
Pathfinder 3 which will be 600 feet long
and 100 feet in diameter with a total
lift of nearly 100 tons why did you come
to this facility just for the the
history and the people but I guess just
in its size offers you something else as
well yes here we are building the
Airship Factory of the future
we can build larger airships here year
round than you can build anywhere else
in the world so that's why we're here
[Music]
if you want to we can probably organize
someone to take you to the top of the
air doctor what is it an elevator or do
I have to climb no there's a funicular
takes you to the top
yeah okay let's go and organize that
[Music]
the funicular we grabbed Harry
Pathfinder 3 program manager and Ohio
local
[Music]
the part where I'm supposed to tell
you 100 year old equipment though
um okay so everybody good all right
ready embraced
[Music]
up goes the 90 year old elevator
have I mentioned I'm not a big fan of
heights
and one more
okay okay
and when you look up it looks kind of
big right but then whenever you get here
and you look down you see like trucks
and those gigantic holy crap it looks
like ants yeah
wow that is crazy
this is making me feel a little queasy
[Music]
when you work with people here or you
grow up around here everybody's got a
story about the air doc whether they're
great grandparents or somebody had
worked here in the past or you have a
lot of family that worked for Goodyear
like I had grandparents that worked at
Goodyear
[Music]
but seeing the blimp overhead it didn't
really mean much as a kid it was a
beautiful thing and it's such a cool
thing to see it but then you realize
well this is really special for for us
right because you know you go a lot of
places you don't really see this and so
you just have this kind of emotional
attachment to it every time you see it
it almost feels like this place has been
waiting patiently for decades for
Airship building to start up again
[Music]
and that's a lovely notion
but there's every reason to think all of
this might fail
Sergey in fact has invested in airships
before
he backed a company called Airship
Ventures that flew people on Joyrides
around the Bay Area
but it folded after a couple of years
long range trips hauling hundreds of
tons of cargo even dicier
so what do you make of LTA and and
Sergey you've got this guy who's got
enough money to do whatever he wants and
it's not even immediately going after
tourism is going more after he says
disaster relief and cargo I mean is it
exciting to see somebody trying to build
a new large ship it must be for you to
have somebody putting money into this
how honest do you want me to be very
honest okay I don't want to to to piss
off any of any of these companies um and
curious them for for giving it a go but
to this day I find it difficult to
imagine the cargo yeah exhaust relief I
find that difficult I think that's going
to take a very long time I'm not saying
it's impossible but it's going to take a
very long time to iron out the issues
with something that big
to try this again now Weston though
remains a True Believer I'm curious
where you see all this going I know when
you give your history of airships you
start by saying I'm out Weston I'm here
to Target the skies which would imply
that you want to make a lot of airships
you know is that the plan or is this is
this you know a limited number of
vehicles for the disaster relief type
efforts where what what are you
picturing from the beginning of this
I've been really intrigued about the
question can these airships be made
quickly and affordably enough to be mass
produced is is does it make sense to
make 100 or a thousand
Studies have suggested that there is a
market but can we actually do it
I think that we're standing on the
shoulders of giants but at the same time
we're leveraging new technologies new
software new materials that the people
of the past could only have dreamed of
I believe that we can make a lot of
airships but we have to complete the
first one right
there are plenty of reasons why airships
aren't practical
they're slow
they're complicated they're expensive
they can only fly in specific weather
conditions
list goes on
but there's a feeling that you get when
you see these massive Sky whales
drifting through the clouds it's a
feeling of Wonder and of Whimsy and I
think it's that feeling that keeps the
dreams of airships Aloft
[Music]